it any of the tags on aaron jones or
does that just not fit with the current
cap situation
yeah we certainly could i think it's
something we're working through i think
again it's not a it's not a
philosophical thing to avoid it i do
think it's there's usually better ways
to go about it but
certainly if i think as we get down the
road here over the next
uh week or so
if that becomes what is in the best
interest of the packers i think we'll do
that um
but at this point you know we haven't we
haven't done that
one week to go for the franchise tags to
be applied the two-week window isn't
necessary no one's been tagged yet it
usually doesn't happen until we get
closer to the deadline aaron jones the
packers running back a candidate for the
application of that tag so he doesn't
hit the market i know that aaron rodgers
a firm believer in aaron jones and the
franchise tag number for running backs
has been dropping in recent years
projected for this year at running back
to be
to be
11.1 i i think it i think they think
it's going to be lower than that based
upon the reduction in the tag it was
12-1 a couple of years ago when le'veon
bell had it the first time but it's a
strange formula now it's a five-year
rolling average based upon the
percentage of the cap that the five
highest paid players at the position
consume it's not like it used to be
where it only looks at the most recent
year but regardless this is a guy the
packers want to keep
and
one way to keep them is to keep them off
the market and you keep them off the
market by using the franchise tag
shireen and i don't know that jones was
so dominant consistently last year that
it makes sense to do it i'm of a mind
and i hate to say this because i love
aaron jones i'm of a mind that you may
be better off looking to the draft or
looking elsewhere to replace that
production because there are so many
guys out there who can perform at a high
level at the running back position
yeah no question about it mike and you
do sound somewhat like mds we know what
he thinks of running backs are
replaceable but they drafted aj dillon
in the second round right and he had a
100 yard game and in week 16 so he
showed what he can do and i think he's
the the replacement that they have jamal
williams also is scheduled to become a
free agent so maybe he would cost them
less to resign there but you know this
is not a team mike that uses the
franchise tag and i know they've said
that it's it's not an organizational uh
decision not to use the tag but let's
look since ted thompson got there since
2005 they've only used it twice and both
were for defensive lineman one was corey
williams and one was ryan pickett the
last one was pickett in 2010
with williams they tagged him and trade
him i could see them doing that with
aaron jones tagging him and them trading
him i don't know that they tag him and
bring him back at that 11 million dollar
mark i just don't think a running back
is worth that much money they are
replaceable you can't get somebody else
to go with a.j dillon i know they love
him i love aaron jones too what he did
two years ago was spectacular but i'm
sorry he's a running back and i just to
have so much money this year that i'm
going to spend it on other positions
other than the running back position
mike
and if it is 11-1 i think if i'm aaron
jones i sign it right away because
that's not a bad payday for one year and
it's unlikely they would tag him again
because he'd get that 20 bump in 2022
like le'veon bell got although he chose
not to play his second year under the
franchise tag
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports